v rappelé la haute autorité de santé a
pu derniers mois élaborer des
recommandations pour l'élaboration d'une
stratégie
quant à la diffusion de ce vaccin la
haute autorité de santé aura de nouveau
l'occasion de se prononcer et de
formuler des recommandations qui nous
permettront de fixer la politique le
public en la matière et en tenant compte
notamment la disponibilité des vaccins
car nous parlons du vaccin développé par
un laboratoire mais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que d'autres laboratoires sont en
phase avancée en phase iii en l'espèce
du développement d'un vaccin je pense à
astrazeneca avec laquelle la commission
européenne avait passé des dés l'été une
pré commandes de doses je pense
également à johnson & johnson
par exemple la haute autorité de santé
devra donc s'exprimer en fonction de la
disponibilité de ces vaccins mais
également tenir compte du profil
spécifique de chacun de ces vaccins
puisque vous le savez peut-être aussi
deux doses pour pfizer une seule dose
pour un certain nombre d'autres vaccins
donc vous voyez qu'il ya encore un
certain nombre de paramètres que nous ne
connaissons pas que nous maîtrisons pas
et sur laquelle la haute autorité de
santé aura à se prononcer afin
d'élaborer cette stratégie que vous
appelez de vos voeux et que nous
partageons évidemment avec une
anticipation je voulais déjà 10 de la
part du gouvernement notamment sur tous
les aspects plus opérationnel et
technique j'évoquais tout à l'heure
la pré commande de matériel permettant
de maintenir à moins 80 degrés ce vaccin
développé par pfizer ce qui ne sera
peut-être pas le cas d'ailleurs des
autres vaccins nous attendons les
résultats des recherches et
permettez-moi enfin monsieur le sénateur
d'ouvrir un petit peu le champ de votre
question à l'international puisque la
question de la disponibilité de
l'universalité de ce vaccin au niveau
mondial est aussi une préoccupation que
le président de la république a exprimé
dès le 24 avril dernier en parlant de
bien public mondial
et c'est ce que nous avons eu ce que
nous évertuerons également de faire est
de promouvoir au niveau international
[Musique]